MALE SPEAKER: Hi,
I'm Alex [INAUDIBLE]
from the Google
Developer Relations team.
I'm happy to announce a new
feature in the Google Maps
JavaScript API.
It's called the Google
Maps Data layer.
Now the Data layer
lets you display
arbitrary geospatial data.
It's a container for any
kind of geospatial data
you can get can in JSON format.
Now what's really
cool about this
is that you can make amazingly
amazing data visualizations.
So one of the
things is, it really
makes it simple to import
GeoJSON data to display
on your map.
You can also style that GeoJSON
data using custom attributes.
So it gives you
a declarative way
of displaying a different
visual experience
for your user, which
is really nice.
Also you can dynamically
change the display client side.
So you can do things like,
use touch input or mouse input
to change the way
your map looks.
And the other thing
that's really, really cool
is you can import GeoJSON data
from multiple data providers
and display the mix
together on a map.
Why don't we have
a look at how you
do that taking a
couple of different
feeds, and we'll show it on
this really cool map of the US
census.
OK, so here we have
a beautiful example
where I've used US
census data to give me
a nice layer on top of my map.
So what we have here is we
have a visual representation
of the people over 25 that
graduated high school.
So I've pulled that data in, and
I've added a mouse [INAUDIBLE]
so that when I move my mouse,
say I move it over California
here, you see it pops up this
little card that tells me
81% of people in California
graduated high school.
And of course, there's
a color grade in here.
So the colors
represent the number
of people that is
coming from that data.
Now what's interesting
about this particular visual
representation is,
these are actually
two GeoJSON feeds
that we've combined.
So the first feed gives
me the state outline.
So the actual shapes
that make up the states
are from one feed, and the
coloring of the populations
comes from the second feed.
So this is an example of mixing
a bunch of different feeds
together on a single map.
OK so now let's take a look
at some of the different ways
that you can import
GeoJSON data from how
you might have done
it in the past.
So maps [? dot ?] data
differs from previous data
feeds like KML layer.
It allows you to
dynamically create things.
You can even use drag and drop.
So let's just have a look
at a little example here.
I've got a file here
containing GeoJSON data,
and I can just drag
it onto the map
and dynamically
create new objects.
So I've created all these
markers in the browser client
site.
It's all rendered there
from a simple GeoJSON file.
Since rendering
happens in the browser,
you can change the
styling dynamically.
So let's take a
look at an example
where we are going
to Chicago and we're
going to change the
styling based on zip code.
OK, so here we've taken
a small GeoJSON file
containing the zip
code boundaries.
And we've used it
to style our map.
You'll note that
each of the polygons
has a different fill and
a different strike color.
We've also added a
mouse [INAUDIBLE].
So if I click on one
of the zip codes,
it changes from red to blue.
Now this is a really
simple example of things
that you can do
fully client side.
The beauty of this
new data layer
is that you can style,
place, and modify
your content or client
side without having
to go back to the server.
So from simple data
visualizations,
to really complicated
visualizations of complex data,
you can all do it client side
with this new data layer.
The thing about this is, as
a JavaScript Maps developer,
this is an awesome
new feature and I
think you'll find
it super useful.
As always, we'll really
happy to get your feedback
on the maps
[? dot ?] data layer.
Head over to our G+ page or
leave comments on this video.
If you have any
technical queries,
go over to Stack Overflow and we
can point you at the right tags
to find out more information.
Looking forward
to your feedback.